Wisconsin Republicans are already
considering impeaching the latest
Supreme Court Justice who just won judge
pertazowitz I hope I'm pronouncing that
correctly uh they're already saying we
may have to consider impeaching her why
well because they want there to be a
conservative majority not because she
did anything wrong they understand that
in order to win in 2024 they might have
to cheat
and one of the places where it would be
useful to cheat would be Wisconsin and
if you don't have control of the Supreme
Court in Wisconsin it's going to be
harder to steal the electoral votes from
the Democratic candidate if the
Democratic candidate wins they are
panicking and they're already looking at
impeachment these people are pathetic